porque ya se cumplieron siete años del
cierre de la frontera entre colombia y
venezuela anunciada el pasado 19 de
agosto del año 2015 esto por el
presidente nicolás maduro inicialmente
era por 72 horas después de que 13
miembros de la fuerza armada venezolana
y un civil resultaran heridos en esa
zona sin embargo los problemas de
venezuela con el país vecino
incrementaron estos tres días se
convirtieron en años en los que la
llegada de iván duque a la presidencia
colombiana no sirvió para mejorar esta
situación en la actualidad la llegada al
poder de gustavo petro generó entonces
esperanza en esta zona fronteriza ya que
reestablecer las relaciones y también
retomar el comercio fronterizo es una de
las prioridades de su agenda de gobierno
el intercambio comercial que se alcanzó
para que tengamos una idea en el año
2014 alcanzó los 2.400 millones de
dólares y se redujo el año pasado a unos
406 millones en los cuales 331 millones
fueron importaciones desde colombia
hacia venezuela saludamos entonces a
nuestro segundo invitado el día él es
carlos luna presidente del comité
intergremial del norte de santander
carlos gracias por estar con nosotros en
directo américa de france 24 también nos
acompaña esta mañana nuestro cronista de
economía luis mendez zúrich gracias raúl
carlos quiero pensar preguntándote
entonces por la importancia de este
comercio fronterizo entre los dos países
se estima que este año se podría
alcanzar los 800 millones de dólares si
esta frontera permanece cerrada porque
como recordemos todavía no tenemos una
fecha establecida no han anunciado
todavía las autoridades de los dos
países cuando realmente se va a reabrir
completamente esta frontera y este
comercio pero podría llegar a los 1.200
millones de dólares y los cruces se
reabren también a los vehículos es esto
posible carlos
bueno muy buenos días para todos los
televidentes de francés 24 y la verdad y
una gran expectativa a partir de el
restablecimiento de relaciones
diplomáticas entre colombia y venezuela
el gobierno del presidente del
gobierno del presidente maduro y no
solamente estamos atentos en la frontera
sino en lo que corresponde el
intercambio y la balanza comercial entre
colombia y venezuela aquí hay dos
situaciones que hay que mirar una el
tema de nuestro relacionamiento
fronterizo entre el estado táchira el
norte de santander y esa población
pendular que viene a buscar en bienes y
servicios históricamente a cúcuta y
nosotros a san cristóbal y otro
obviamente el restablecimiento de paso
comercial por las aduanas entre
venezuela y colombia por san antonio del
táchira y cúcuta fundamental para
restablecer la legalidad que se ha
perdido en estos años porque el
intercambio se hace de contrabando por
las trochas el paso hasta el año pasado
se hacía también por el río y por las
trochas afectando la vida de millones de
personas que tuvieron que hacerlo y
ahora se hace por los puentes pero
estamos esperando en el restablecimiento
del paso vehicular para que lleguen más
d 50 mil vehículos diarios y
restablezcan y reactivar la economía
fronteriza ahora carlos y armando
benedetti el embajador nombrado por el
gobierno de gustavo petro para venezuela
habló de un intercambio comercial que
podía alcanzar los 10 mil millones de
dólares es esta cifra viable entre estos
dos países cuando su mayor tasa de
intercambio comercial fue alrededor de
2008-2009 por el orden de los 7.000
entre 5 y 7 mil millones de dólares
pues yo creo que es un mensaje que
refleja el optimismo que tienen los
empresarios y obviamente ambos países en
ese sentido pero las cifras de la cámara
colombo-venezolana implica que indica
que va a ser al finalizar de este año
entre 800 y 1000 millones de dólares
como bien lo decía en ustedes y crecer
exponencialmente para que termine y
finalizar el gobierno del presidente de
petro entre 4 ó 5 mil millones de
dólares pero creo que hay posibilidades
de que crezca obviamente en este nuevo
relacionamiento porque se podrán
desarrollar además de los intercambios
históricos que se tienen entre colombia
y venezuela pues potencializar el tema
de energías en tema de desarrollo de
energía de carbón y de petróleo entre
colombia y venezuela de gas y podría
llegar a niveles que han planteado el
embajador benedetti en un escenario
ideal y optimista pero lo fundamental es
arrancar restablecer el paso vehícular
restablecer el paso las aduanas y esto
se hará a partir de que los embajadores
placencia y benedetti estén en bogotá de
carácter carlos también hablabas de una
legalidad comercial aduanera que tan
fácil o qué tan difícil es volver a
instaurar la después de tanto tiempo de
estos pasos fronterizos cerrados
legalmente no además le pregunto la
seguridad que pueden tener los
empresarios de las empresas colombianas
en el territorio venezolano la seguridad
comercial la seguridad institucional de
que pues si realmente funcionen de sus
empresas y no tengan ningún riesgo de a
lo mejor puede ser expropiadas o
cualquier otro tipo de situación
y aquí en los últimos años se perdió el
comercio de legal es innegable que en la
frontera y en todas las fronteras de
américa latina
generan fenómenos de contrabando por
diferencias económicas entre algunos
productos pero aquí se perdió
absolutamente ese intercambio no pasa
por las aduanas de 'san antonio' ningún
camión desde hace más de tres años desde
el famoso concierto del año 2019 lo que
nos dejó fue los contagios en los
puentes e intercambio legales bloqueado
como tal yo creo que la seguridad en la
frontera en el primer paso se hará
cuando se restablezca y la gente pueda
venir a hacer el intercambio de manera
legal y los productos lleguen igualmente
y la seguridad jurídica puede se debe
dar en el marco este nuevo
restablecimiento para que se puedan
generar obviamente sean inversiones y
esos desarrollos de complementariedad e
integración entre colombia y venezuela y
es parte del trabajo diplomático de
recuperar de que reconstruir estas
relaciones que fueron destruidas en los
últimos años
ahora carlos si bien es cierto que es
importante primero adecuar las aduanas
para poder establecer estas relaciones
comerciales qué tan importante será para
colombia y venezuela retomar acuerdos
del pasado que beneficiaron mucho a
ambas economías en este caso específico
la zona de libre comercio acuerdos
comerciales con tasas impositivas de
beneficios para ambos países
yo creo que ambos países han venido
preparando en medidas que incentiven la
inversión en la frontera en el caso de
venezuela tiene sus zonas económicas
especiales en todo el país y estamos
esperando que obviamente se promulga el
estado táchira y en el caso de colombia
además de el régimen franco y de
potencialidades que se puedan tener en
la instalación de un proyectado puerto
set buen puerto logístico para ese
intercambio entre colombia y venezuela y
la salida por el puerto de la ceiba el
lago maracaibo de grandes grandes
producciones de carbón y que sea el
puerto del oriente de colombia está
también claro que es fundamental que se
pueda establecer vamos más allá de estas
medidas desarrollar lo que es las zonas
económicas especiales en colombia'
sociales es un beneficio de renta y en
retención en la fuente que también
estaba planteado pero que no se pudo
desarrollar estos últimos años por lo
que cierra la frontera
y por el ivam ente por la patria que
también afectó carlos ya rápidamente
para finalizar nuestra conversación
y los retos de esta reapertura de la
frontera una zona plagada de grupos
ilegales grupos al margen de la ley pues
para que todo este
intercambio comercial se dé pues también
tiene que haber la seguridad no
yo creo que la seguridad se va a
recuperar cuando se restablezcan las
relaciones cuando se coordinen las dos
autoridades porque es que de estos
últimos años nadie respondió para la
frontera y llegó al vaivén de los grupos
armados de los ilegales y de la
ilegalidad total eso se accederá a dar
cuando las autoridades tengan que
responder de colombia y de venezuela por
la línea limítrofe y eso es fundamental
y eso nos dará la tranquilidad de que
los empresarios pueden venir a
invertir tanto en el touch y en toda la
línea fronteriza en la guajira del zulia
arau entonces fundamental que eso se dé
y dar a la seguridad el restablecimiento
de las relaciones diplomáticas estamos
absolutamente seguro y esperamos que sea
así